my name is Ryan Johnson and I am very
very excited to show you guys an
exclusive scene from my new movie it's
the follow-up to knives out and it is
called Glass Onion the Mystery Begins
when a group of old friends all receive
an unexpected invitation in the form of
a intricate puzzle box but what starts
as a game turns into something much more
nefarious I will shut up at this point
and let you watch the clip but I hope
you enjoy it thank you
oh
[Applause]
a whole new tune
freaking miles man
genius at First Once A Fibonacci
sequence
[Music]
I'll get your hand off of them
oh oh
47 for sure that's the atomic number for
Silver are you sure that's silver that's
silver
[Music]
all together now one two three
[Music]
look at that
[Music]
okay
my dear friends my beautiful disruptors
my closest Inner Circle we could all use
a moment of normalcy and so you are
cordially invited for a long weekend on
my
friend where we will celebrate the bonds
that connect us and I hope your puzzle
solving skills are wetted
because you will also be competing to
solve the mystery
of my murder
travel details to come please forward
any dietary restrictions love and all my
kisses miles
ma where's my spear gun I gotta pack get
back
what's up
I don't know
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen this invitation is
not to be trifled
[Music]